hello everyone
various institutes across the country
have started the process of going back
to offline classes and exams and here at
iit kharagpur also it has been recently
declared officially that at the end of
this semester we are going to have
offline exams now this news has been
greeted too by many in the student
community with a collective gasp of
disappointment
the general mood and feeling is that
while the pandemic was bad for almost
everything but for one aspect increasing
grades in exams
it was definitely like a blessing
how did that happen how did the pandemic
help to increase the grades well we can
posit a number of reasons for this
one could say that perhaps when the
students went back to their parents
under the attentive care or at home
maybe because of the food maybe because
of parental love and affection
they became slightly more disciplined
they suffered from less distractions and
then ended up getting more marks but i
think
such kind of reasoning is basically
shying away from the actual truth
which is that grades increased because
of rampant and flagrant cheating now
when i say rampant and flagrant cheating
what i mean is that some kind of nexus
was created among some of these cheating
students not all mind you
and we are going to come to honor
students uh very quickly now
this nexus of students what they did was
divide up the questions in an
examinations amongst themselves solve it
individually collect the solutions and
then share the solutions through mail
whatsapp or discord in some extreme
situations some professors have even
reported that they suspect that some
kind of professional help on over the
internet was also taken by some students
by some unscrupulous students now the
sad truth is that
many of the professors were well aware
of all of these things
but they could not do anything in the
absence of hard irrefutable evidence but
it's not really true that we did not do
anything we did take some measures to
curb the effects of cheating
but truth be told what happened was that
we realized that no matter what we did
it always seemed like the cheating
students would always be one step ahead
of us so on and on we went in this
endless game of two police
now some of you may be laughing at all
of this and perhaps it's a little bit
funny but if you think about it for a
moment don't you think that this
kind of vitiated the entire atmosphere
of learning and evaluation and you know
what were the worst sufferers in this
fiasco is the honest students amongst
you so you suffered in various ways the
direct way in which you suffered was
that while on the one hand you were
studying very honestly for your exams
trying to perform the best in those
exams you could say all around you
students were perhaps less capable than
you and perhaps who had goofed off
enormously and lazily all throughout the
semester they were getting more marks
and higher grades than you there was
another indirect mode of suffering as i
said earlier some of the professors had
taken some measures to curb the cheating
and one of these measures was to set
harder questions so that even though
some of the cheating students
collaborated amongst themselves they
would still find it hard to answer the
individual questions now you can imagine
if
if the questions were set in such a way
that in spite of collaboration they
would find it harder imagine if an
honest student trying to answer this the
these questions on their own without
taking anyone else's help how much
harder will it be from for them
therefore this decision of going back to
offline exams i think it will be most
welcomed not by the professors but by
these honest students
there was actually another kind of
suffering which the honest students had
gone through
so uh initially many of these students
had tried to uh to stay honest and uh
and not take part in any of these unfair
means but as time went by they saw that
they were getting repeatedly beaten by
these dishonest students so ultimately
they just gave up i mean you can only
take so much damage and you can give so
much sacrifice ultimately they also
became dishonest so they went against
their core nature of honesty and
integrity
so that's why i think this kind of an
offline exam will be a much much welcome
respite from all these darker things so
this is about the state of affairs
now let's talk about the consequences of
these offline exams
i believe
and
this is quite obvious that
during this offline exams what is going
to happen is that these students these
cheating students who have become so
much reliant on whatsapp messages and
discord and whatnot there they are going
to finally get caught out their grades
are going to decrease
and basically
it's game over for them and for all
those
false nine pointers out there but what
are the long term consequences of this
so these cheating students their
academic record is going to show up a
peculiar trend before the pandemic hit
their scores would be low
during the time of the online exams this
course would suddenly increase and then
once we go back to the
offline exams their grades would again
decrease
so this kind of a trend in the academic
record it will be a clear and
unmistakable indication that these
students were not just academically less
capable but they were also dishonest all
right their overall grades
may increase we get boost up a little
bit because of what happened during the
online exams uh
the higher grades that they managed to
get through cheating
but this trend of low high low this will
remain forever etched into their
academic record and this is an academic
disgrace that they'll have to carry all
throughout their life now some of you
may be thinking that all right so what i
mean
it's ultimate is the ultimate great
point average that matters but no
i'm quite sure that in the coming years
when it comes for academic kind of
positions and academic interviews when
your transcript is actually looked at by
the professors they will look at this
trend and you will get caught out all
right
some of you
among the
some of the cheating students
they might be thinking that
they somehow managed through unfair
means during the online exams and they
will continue like this during the
offline exams also and uh they will they
manage to get higher grades and here you
are completely wrong okay they'll be
completely wrong on this you see
during the online exams the professors
truth be told were completely
inexperienced okay we did not have
sufficient experience to catch the
cheating and the various unfair means
the students were ahead of us these
teaching students but when it comes to
offline exams there is a wealth of
experience that we can rely on handed
out handed down to us over generations
and generations and don't forget that
all of us have experience as students
ourselves in this offline exams so we
all we know all the inside tricks the
various kinds of unfair means various
permutations and combinations of unfair
means and malpractices the students have
done first
by looking at those kinds of uh of
cheating students when we were students
ourselves and then as faculty members
through our invalidation duty we have
come across so many different kinds of
uh these cases that we know all the
tricks that the students the the
cheating students employ so there is a
distinct possibility that you will be
caught unlike the case of online exams
furthermore there are extremely
stringent and formal measures in place
to handle with such kinds of unfair
means
for example here at iit kharagpur itself
if a student is caught cheating he'll
have to face
a disciplinary committee a formal
disciplinary committee his first his
answer script would be sealing an
envelope and sent to the disciplinary
committee then the student has to face
the disability committee and some kind
of punishment will be handed out to him
appropriate to the kind of
malpractice that he has committed
so it can happen that the subject
registration of the student is gets
cancelled it's a very very common thing
okay and the student has to wait till
the next semester or perhaps even up to
a year
when that subject is offered again so
that effectively he gets uh at least a
semester and sometimes even a year back
okay so these kinds of extreme things
can happen and i'm not just making this
up okay these kinds of things have
happened earlier
now these are all dark and negative
things that i have been talking about i
want to end this video on some kind of a
positive note okay so what i want to
think what i want to believe is that uh
once the offline exam start even some of
the students at least some of the
students who had
engaged in these kinds of unfair means
now what they will think is that they
have to maintain their reputation
and my hope is that some at least some
of them will start studying very
seriously
if not for anything else just to save
their face in front of their friends
okay and uh
is something like this they know very
well that if they start getting less
mark suddenly a lower grade suddenly
they will get caught out in front of
their friends and uh they will be at the
receiving end of various kinds of
merciless jokes and dawns and they want
to avoid that so
no so this is my hope okay that's even
some of the
so-called bad students will now become
good
okay but who knows maybe i'm being a
hopeless optimist okay but on this note
i'll end this video thank you very much